[Music]
[Music]
you don't make it easy
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story is this the room you
grew up in uh it it is but uh my my dorm
room is very adult right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
society
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am queen of the most powerful nation
in the world
and my entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
and when i wake up
[Music]
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born
out of rage
[Music]
this loose cannon needs to be locked
down
before innocent people start getting
hurt
he's been asleep for 5 000 years
if you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the rest who's on the
team
i didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
we're the justice society
black adam we're here to negotiate your
peaceful
i'm surrender peaceful
nor do i surrender
here we go
i knew before no one
[Music]
you didn't come here to seek justice
you came to exact revenge
[Music]
i never said i was a hero
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman it's so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me superpowers
then everybody got super powers is
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
come on now get down to business
business listen to me billy the fate of
the world depends on it
around what is
this coming for you
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was the signal
introducing the star of
[Music]
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
i just threw a truck and a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
what do you do with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good that is what you make meredith dead
i pick up garbage for a living about the
same thing smeared and cleaned up the
streets
you mind your business on my mind i
don't believe you
are you okay
oh cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop caring
and i stopped caring a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
[Music]
hey old man
try this
please
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
what's black
and blue
and dead all over
i got you
[Music]
kids get the popcorn out let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god after saving planet earth
for the 500th time thor set off on a new
journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
am i um sensing feelings
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back
there just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
you
are not like the other gods that kill
him
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
every night
i dreamed the same dream
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can control everything strange
[Music]
you opened the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wonder
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules look out
and become a hero
i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
it doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Music]
hello
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's cursing
my cool
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now i face a choice to hunt
and consume blood
don't die we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
all right tv night with my pro
[Applause]
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh
hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is
i have an owner
[Music]
with other animals this just seems gross
we need gross smelling stuff is one of
the greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumbo in the
back
hey deploy k-9 here what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why can't i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
you